well joining me now is the journalist
adam bolton an author ella well welcome
to both of you uh great to see you leave
that photograph
one day i'll tell the real story but it
was uh it was a proud moment uh adam
great to have you uh one of the great
doings of of the television journalism
industry
you better than most people in this
country can put into proper perspective
where we are with partygate because
every time i hear somebody going
it doesn't matter we should move on i
feel the shackles
rising inside me because i think it does
matter and we shouldn't move on am i
wrong am i am i
exaggerating the scale of this yeah i
think it does matter for two reasons
first of all because we all went through
the pandemic all of us had to change our
lives you had long covered and yeah and
all the rest of it and we all changed
our behavior people who were telling us
to do that and punishers if we didn't
were the government and they were going
on television saying that now if they
weren't obeying their own rules i think
that's very serious
and and it's an example
of a serious matter which now looks a
bit trivial because we feel we're past
the pandemic and you know what what
about policy so i think that's the first
reason why it matters the second reason
why it matters
is because it matters
to have a government we can trust and if
you have a government there
that has consistently had to change its
story been proven to say things which
aren't true i mean just look at this
latest stuff about boris johnson leaning
on uh sue gray not to publish her i mean
really shocking yeah
and initially they said oh there wasn't
a meeting then they said it was a
meeting she asked for then they had to
admit uh that he asked for it and now we
have this evidence uh coming in the
times that you know they were trying to
sit on the whole inquiry which has
dominated politics for the past six
months all of that matters yeah i
totally agree and ella i mean i read
there's a bbc documentary panorama
around tonight which has a litany of
detail about what was going on at these
parties from people who were there and
when you see the scale of it and the
sort of the impunity that these people
at the heart of downing street were
behaving whilst everybody else was
obeying the laws they'd laid down even
to the extent that they were
saying to some officials at downey
street mocking them
for expressing even a raised eyebrow
about what was going on actually mocking
people for saying shouldn't you not be
doing this
it's quite shocking when you get into
the weeds of this
isn't it call me a cynic but i'm you
know politicians acting with impunity
lying no you know do having one rule for
them one for us
no it's not a good thing it's not a good
thing we should never tolerate it but it
was ever thus and i think one of you i
think you're absolutely right that we
shouldn't forget this but not
potentially for the reasons that you're
saying because the most frustrating
thing for me is that this is you know
this scandal over how the government
acted and indeed opposition party acted
however bondage throughout a pandemic
has boiled down to the question of a pcn
and whether or not you know holding a
drink like that constitutes a party and
that really trivializes i think the
central point of this which is
what do we actually care about because
parties in and of themselves in the
abstract there's no problem with it the
problem was that the government was that
members of government and civil servants
and that were having a good time while
they were legislating to criminalize
people who sat together right
to me it's not about parties yeah but
it's about the brazen hypocrisy and
double standard but for the future i
think what's important to recognize is
that you know boris johnson and other
cabinet ministers are still dangling the
prospect of lockdown measures and things
like that for the future and i think
what we have to the the real world why
would anyone trust a word they say well
the real reason we have to hold them to
account is to say what really was the
tragedy and what really was the thing
that was wrong was that you criminalized
people who sat next to each other on a
bench particularly in the latter stages
of the last two years
not that you had a party so i just want
people to get their priorities well in a
way that's a secondary issue because
they did make those laws now you can
argue about whether they should or
whether they should again i think it's
the primary issue because i think well
no because well i don't i don't think it
changes the hypocrisy if you make laws
you've got to abide by them yourselves
right i mean it would probably be
different next time around people have
learned from it but at the time that's
what they were telling us to do and they
weren't doing it themselves and and
it does come down to trust and and yes
it's trivial parties but what's becoming
clear
is boris johnson is a very trivial prime
minister and also he's not someone who
is wading into the big issues who has a
clue
yeah that's what we may have always
known
he's a liar i'm sorry yeah but he's been
you know he's been fired from several
jobs in the past for lying and he's been
lying about these parties he's stood
there in parliament and said everything
was above board all on the rules that
party we're told now by people who were
there up to 30 people
were on the lash apparently it was every
friday of four o'clock the press team
all had a knees up but i mean he's he's
debased everybody's he's reduced us to
arguing about when is a party a party
yeah and you know does hold your glass i
mean it which i find you know
humiliating i mean we we know what a
party yes exactly yeah but then on top
of that
what we're seeing is junior people in
downing street carrying the can they're
the ones they're the ones who've been
fined and you know if your boss says
we're having a party you go you may not
want to go
and we know that 50 percent of the
people invited to the downing street
party didn't go but a junior person an
ambitious person will go if their boss
throws it but ultimately adam i mean the
only way boris johnson will go is not
what you or i think or what even the
british public think until an election
the only way is if 56 tory mps decide
that his behavior and the sue grey
report is due out tomorrow and may be
more damning than we're even expecting
but if it's just more of the same in
huge detail could it trigger enough tory
mps to actually
grow a pair get a conscience and send in
letters to have a leadership election
yeah i do think it could because i think
if it is clear to the conservatives that
he's become a liability and you know
remember since this broke they've been
behind in the polls and boris johnson is
currently less popular than the
conservative party now they're not going
to put up with that forever except if
you have the argument that the next
election's a good one to lose but that's
not what most politicians think and ella
on uh one other issue today which is
what was big in the news afghanistan
the the british role in that absolute
debacle of a overnight departure which
betrayed all the afghan people looked
about as shameful as the americans when
you actually get into the the detail of
this report was come out yeah i mean if
you were waiting for the report to
inform your decision about you know what
how we handled this you obviously
weren't watching the footage that we all
saw at the time of people standing in
sewage scrambling for planes these are
people that took a risk working with the
british government and um i'm really
sick of uh watching and listening to all
the crocodile tears from certain um
conservative mps about how difficult
this was to handle yes or indeed from
people within the foreign office about
how hard they worked because quite
simply this was from the start
mishandled and also i think it's not
just a case of people not catching
emails it fundamentally shows from both
the uk and the us perspective the
disregard with which the west treats
people in nations that it meddles in and
under the grotesque betrayal of the
afghan people where you now have the
women in particular you know even female
tv presenters having to wear masks now
on television not because i've covered
but because the taliban have all of them
to put veils on it i think it's
completely shameful let me ask you a
question adam what do you know about
monkey pox
much it's not as bad as kovid right it
looks worse but it's not so i've got to
be honest with you i've not really got
into the weeds of monkey pox do you know
much about it ella you know i know that
a little bit it looks a bit sore but i
don't get it i was out today with my
middle son he's a young guy he hasn't
got microphone no but he shares a flap
with another actor called alex heath who
it turns out is a bit of an expert on
monkey box because he posted something
to tick-tock two days ago that has now
had nine million views in two days it's
a sensation on tinto and it's a simple
30-second explainer of monkey box and i
thought it'd be interesting just to play
it here's monkey pox by should you be
worried about monkey pox as quick as i
can so it's a disease that leaves you
with a fever fatigue and a rash that
wears off in a couple of weeks there's
been a small number of outbreaks before
but the way it's been able to spread is
hard to ignore see normally outbreaks
have stayed in one place but this week
it's been seen in several states and so
the who's expected to investigate
whether the strain's spreading
undetected should you be worried not
really if you're relatively healthy it
wouldn't hit you severely in either case
antivirals make it more treatable but
it's feasible but in the next few weeks
or so you'll see an awful lot of news
stories on it some papers will generate
clickbait from it there are concerns
about the viruses behavior but bear in
mind postpartum panic sales papers
jonathan van tan eat your heart out you
know what's fascinating about it is
there's this whole world on tick-tock
which i i'm sort of loosely aware of it
but nine million views in two days for
just a young young actor not that well
known i'm sure he will be he's talented
but it's fascinating isn't it there's
this other world where young people are
getting information like that about big
issues like monkeybugs well it's also
it's you know the thing about tiktok is
people talk about as a young people
saying it's a very young people's thing
so i'm i'm thirsty i don't consider
myself as a little too old but it's
completely beyond me are you a tick-tock
no i didn't look at it but i couldn't
get it to work
great to see you both thank you very
much i've got a feeling we'll be seeing
you again because i think it's going to
be a big week for boris johnson maybe
one of his last in office if what we
believe is in this report comes out